greetings I'm Walter Bernays yak and
this is top five here we countdown the
best and worst performances of our most
beloved actors today we take a look at
the best of Johnny Depp savvy Johnny
Depp is without a doubt one of the best
actors of his generation from the
beginning he's pushed the envelope in
ways that other actors wouldn't dare
his range from playing lovably goofy
characters to stone-cold killers and
everything in between is well documented
the guy can pretty much do anything he's
created icons while crafting a career
that spans 32 years when death is on his
game he's one of the best screen
presences maybe ever and these are the
best of the best his top 5 best
performances number 5 agent Sheldon
Jeffrey sands in Once Upon a Time in
Mexico this is probably not what you
were expecting
once upon a time in Mexico is the last
and director Robert Rodriguez as Mexico
trilogy it features some amazing action
and is quite underrated but Johnny Depp
100% steals the show this is the coolest
performance of his whole career the
mythical hero el Mariachi returns this
time he's caught in the middle of a war
between drug cartels CIA and FBI agents
plus the haunting memories of the death
of his family in the battle for Mexico l
must navigate through all the players in
this game while trying to take revenge
on the man who murdered his wife and
daughter we all know Antonio Banderas is
cool he exudes it in this character so
it says a lot when Depp as agent sands
out does him in the charisma Department
the attitude that he shows off here is
effortlessly magnetic are you a Mexican
or a mexican't it is so good that when
I'm finished with it I'll pee my chair
walk straight into the kitchen and shoot
the cook because that's what I do I
restore the balance to this country
savvy this is the perfect mix of Depp
getting to show off his comedic side
with some great dry humor and
legitimately being a badass throughout
the film especially towards the end and
a lot of the time they go hand in hand
you know that withholding vital
information
from a federal officer is a serious
offense especially when that officer has
paid handsomely for it and wouldn't
think twice about ripping that patch off
your eye hole and skull-fucking you to
death this is the kind of character
who's supposed to be an undercover CIA
agent but we're CIA t-shirts in public
he just does not give a crap every time
he's on screen you're hanging on his
unpredictability is he going to say a
cool funny line or suddenly shoot the
person he's talking to you never know
and it keeps him interesting see
anything you like
now the end of the film contained his
best scenes and they are so much fun to
watch this character's appeal rivals
that of Jack Sparrow and I had to put it
in at number five if you're a fan of
Rodriguez's non Kid movie style go check
this one out
number four James Whitey Bulger in Black
Mass this one just came out last year
and proves Depp can still give us fresh
and unsettling performances based on a
true story Whitey Bulger was a
small-time Boston gangster when he's
approached by his old friend John
Connolly to become an FBI informant over
the following years Bulger abuses his
status and corrupts his FBI friends to
the point where he became one of the
biggest crime bosses in US history the
rise and fall of Bulger's empire are
chronicled in this tale from the
beginning Depp is a heavy intimidating
presence he's unhinged and creepy but he
could also be somewhat sympathetic those
different sides to Bulger's personality
make this one of Depp's best the element
of not knowing when Bulger will snap
makes you keep an eye on him at all
times one second he's your friend the
next he's strangling you to death those
scenes are terrifying it makes you think
how a man you seemed to love his mother
wife and son so much can be so angry and
cold in brutally murdering people by far
the creepiest scene is when he confronts
John Connally's wife it made my skin
crawl
and he saw on is there something I don't
feel any swollen glands do the only
thing I'd say against this performance
is that the makeup on depth doesn't
quite work he looks like an alien with
the blue eye contacts they never looked
good on people with naturally dark eyes
it's weird because the age progression
on everyone else in the movie is great
that's the only one who doesn't look
right
I think they should have just blended
Depp's natural features with a few
elements of Bulger's look other than
that this is one of Depp's best and
shows us just how dark he can go number
three
Edward Scissorhands in Edward
Scissorhands this was the genesis of a
partnership that continues to this day
Johnny Depp and Tim Burton's first
collaboration together is still arguably
their best when suburban saleswoman peg
discovers a young man with scissors for
hands in the attic of an abandoned old
mansion she takes the gentle Edward to
live with her and her family Edward
eventually Falls for Peg's daughter and
after a while the townspeople turn on
him citing his freakish hands and
inability to distinguish right from
wrong as the reasons for out casting him
when I was younger I didn't even realize
that depth played Edward he's very quiet
and soft-spoken with minimal dialogue
and still kind of hard to recognize him
the good stuff from Depp comes in a lot
of how he innocently interacts with the
world around him he's so sympathetic
that you're on his side from the start
while seeing just how much he doesn't
fit into this perfect suburban setting
many times its humorous but that's also
the real tragedy of the character I love
how people don't initially react to
Edward as that much of a freak he sort
of seen that way at the beginning but
it's not as big of a deal as you would
think they only really treat him badly
later on this is a Tim Burton movie that
feels so fresh nowadays it still has all
his trademarks but for some reason
Edward Scissorhands seems so honest and
sincere I wish I could say that about
all his work the little facial
expressions and reactions that Depp
sprinkles throughout this movie are
genius it's a sweet story by Burton that
no one else could have pulled off this
is deaf at his best well third best
number two let's get on with it already
mate there's no need for the foreplay
we all know what number one is you can
skip to through five
let me guess you're a Jim Sparrow
captain Jim Sparrow number two Captain
Jack Sparrow and Pirates of the
Caribbean curse of the Black Pearl
that's er wait what the Black Pearl is a
mysterious ship that houses a cursed
crew led by their captain Barbosa when
they stormed Port Royal to find a
missing piece of treasure that could
lift their curse they kidnapped the
daughter of the governor Elizabeth Swann
and leave the former captain of the
Black Pearl Jack Sparrow teams up with
blacksmith will Turner to chase them
down and recover both Jack's beloved
ship and Will's beloved Elizabeth based
off my favorite ride at Disneyland this
will be created a pop culture icon in
Jack Sparrow he's now one of the most
popular movie characters in history and
I think it's safe to say it's now what
Depp is most identified with Depp's
charisma and likeability are at an
all-time high with this performance
people love Jack Sparrow and we all know
why he's fun funny smart witty a
troublemaker and pretty much the closest
live-action version of a Bugs Bunny type
character I think we'll ever get I
wanted to mention that I don't think
Geoffrey Rush's Barbosa gets enough
credit for his performance he's the
perfect foil for Jack and also create
and that kind of character so let's not
forget about him when we talk about
Pirates of the Caribbean Depp isn't just
all style with no substance as Sparrow
either there's still some really good
motivations underneath all the eye
makeup and slurred speech that's what a
ship is you know there's no just a keel
and a hole in the deck and sails as the
ship needs
but what a ship is but the black pearl
really is is freedom
I love Pirates of the Caribbean while
the sequels never measured up to the
original they're still entertaining to
watch yes even on Stranger Tides death
as Captain Jack is that franchise
without him it wouldn't be what it is
today son I'm Captain Jack Sparrow heavy
what could beat Jack Sparrow well just
one performance Johnny Depp has some
amazing work that I can't fit into just
five rolls so before we get to number
one
here are some honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Johnny Depp
performance is Edward D Wood jr. in Ed
Wood I love it would the movie and this
performance by Depp are near perfection
as a filmmaker I identify with his
struggles and in terms of making movies
I may be more like him than I care to
admit Ed Wood doesn't exactly fit in as
a Hollywood director his strange
personality and eccentric script ideas
make him an outsider however a chance
meeting with former Dracula Bayliss
Lugosi
starts to change all that with a team of
misfits at his side ed manages to create
an oddly appealing string of super low
budget movies the undying optimistic
energy that depth charges into this
performance is spectacular he is so
funny and relatable in a way that
everyone can appreciate he's a schemer
with a heart of gold and I love every
second he's on screen sound we don't
have sound oh and action mr. woo ha I
only got one hours sleep last night yeah
well I got no sleep and I feel great go
get him kid Eddie's only fella in town
who doesn't pass judgment that's right
if I did I wouldn't have any friends the
foundation of this film is the
friendship between Edward and Bella
Lugosi Martin Landau is astonishing as
the former horror star and his
relationship with his dear Eddie is
hilarious but very authentic and
heartwarming they're there for each
other in ways I wouldn't have expected
they're just a great team it'll warm up
once you're in it
fuck you you'll come out here
[Applause]
the amount of joy that Johnny Depp as
edwood brings into this world is
something that this planet needs more of
he concocted a performance that is
hysterical relatable and genuine in my
opinion it's his best I want to hear
what you guys think what is your
favorite Johnny Depp performance and/or
movie who do you want me to cover next
on the show leave a comment and let me
know follow me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter and come back next
week when we count down the top 5 worst
Johnny Depp performances till then
goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
you